agnès buzyn olivier ferrand et edouard
philippe trois ministres ou ex-ministres
visé par des plaintes pour non
assistance à personne en danger et
homicide involontaire dans leur gestion
de la crise du coc vide 19 s'est plainte
datée ria la cour de justice de la
république
mais c'est quoi au juste la cour de
justice de la république
leymen gâchis la cour de justice de la
république a été créée en 1993
c'est le tribunal chargé des crimes et
délits commis par des membres du
gouvernement
avant ça seuls les sénateurs et les
députés pouvaient attaquer le
gouvernement en justice
et c est à eux de les juger désormais
tout citoyen peut porter plainte contre
un ministre l'autre nouveauté c'est la
composition de cette cour six sénateurs
six députés auxquels s'ajoutent trois
magistrats une cour - politique donc
salué par jack lang alors membre de
l'opposition pour la justice j'ai besoin
d'indépendance de la justice est motivée
par une affaire celle du sang contaminé
le plus grand scandale sanitaire
français du xxème siècle des médecins et
le gouvernement sont impliqués et les
questions de dix mille personnes environ
qui ont été contaminées sans le savoir
au début des années 80 dans ce dossier
des médecins ont été jugés en 1992
devant le tribunal de grande instance
pour les ministres il faut attendre sept
ans en 1999 leur procès a lieu devant la
cour de justice de la république
au terme d'un mois de débats relaxe pour
l'ex premier ministre laurent fabius et
pour l'ex ministre des solidarités
georgina dufoix
l'ancien secrétaire d'état à la santé
edmond hervé le seul reconnu coupable
dispensé de peine et je me suis rendu
compte c'est que
et politique c'est comme les gangsters
si on les compare la main dans le sac
jamais les coincer la cour de justice de
la république est critiqué dans le monde
juridique comme dans l'arène politique
pour sa supposée complaisance en 27 ans
d'existence sur huit ministres et
secrétaires d'état juge et trois ont été
déclarés non coupables de coupables
dispensé de peine et trois condamnées à
de la prison avec sursis d'autres
estiment que cette juridiction
d'exception et un privilège c'est le cas
de françois hollande en 2012 soit
président de la république puis pendant
la campagne il promet de supprimer la
cour basée à la fin de son mandat il
n'en sera rien en 2017 c'est au tour du
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron de s'y
attaquer dans sa réforme de la
constitution
nous instaurerons l'obligation pour les
membres du gouvernement d'être jugés par
des magistrats
cette réforme était prévue pour 2018
elle a été décalée pour cause de gilet
jaune représenté en 2019 et toujours
sans suite clairement définis